hello and again welcome to the Aperture
Science computer-aided Enrichment Center
today you will be testing with a partner
please wait to your partner good maybe
upcoming tests required you to work
together as a team
okay so we'll start out a little bit
slow here Skyler if you just want to run
up and grab that portal gun it says go
acquire a portal device blew up as a
quarter glass by your name so Skylar if
you can head on through that door this
is the portal gun that you had in portal
1 same thing it fires two portals on the
right left trigger and if you can do me
a favor Skylar and put one portal
straight ahead of you there on that wall
and then kind of up into your left put
your red or a little bit yeah aren't
there okay then head on through and then
make a lab so what you saw there was me
as Skylar's partner actually trying to
tell him where to put a portal and using
just words we found it it's actually
kind of difficult to tell somebody where
here or there is so we've introduced
something we call the pink tool to help
with that okay cool is it valuable
information is do you still see Connor
has marked up the environment using the
paint tool so that Skylar can see
immediately where he wants skylar to put
his portal since now if you just do that
there
perfect al kamen can get around that
wall and if you guys move forward and
Skylark if you click on the right stick
you can place your own pain so if you
want to mark the wall up your job he
knows where you want to the corrals and
then head on through perfect and that's
it that's your first portal puzzle good
job and I'm proving the elevators
excellent Oh hooray science is always
the result of collaboration keep in mind
like Albert Einstein and cousin Terry
history
so just to give you some idea the
lengths of them coop the coop track is
about twice as long as portal once i
attain was and portal to single player
campaign is also about twice as long a
lot of new content that we're putting
into the sequel alright so some of the
new content if you look on Gotham screen
see that kind of people looking being
there that's what we call a thermal
discouragement beam and it's one of the
new puzzle elements we've got and what
we need to do is actually get that beam
through Skylar if you can turn to your
right there you go those two little
things on the floor our laser perceptor
and we need to get the beam through that
God was going to pick up this
funny-looking feud here it's a
reflective human to see that you can use
it to direct the be wherever he wants it
to go and
that's kind of look out in time so what
these guys need to do is somehow get the
beam through the walls and Gotham is
going to put down and chatter portals to
drill a hole through the first wall all
right so you're halfway there Skylar if
you can complete the circuit by drilling
through the second wall
perfect now the door is open so that's
your first of simple for proof
commiserate this is not a competition
still if it were orange would be me it's
not though so if you watch any of the
single-player videos we release probably
have seen the thermal discouragement
beep alarm gels and catapults in the
excursion funnel all of those elements
are in coop as well both co-op the
single-player share complete set of
puzzle elements alright so this is a new
puzzle element that we haven't showed
the ports on the hard light grey and
government you can stick a portal where
the bridge meets the wall and then one
up above you'll see that the portals can
extend the bridge you can create a safe
walkway across obstacles so you guys can
hop on that parade and then walk through
the portal you can fill
cross the goon dead there go ahead
skylar through there once you move
forward be careful that he's deadly
you've been here there's a Ledge down
there and then we're Skylar's looking
right now that's where they need to go
around that then they're so Donovan is
going to cover that goob that's directly
in front of them with the laser brain
building 7 ok perfect if you guys can
carefully walk out on the bridge and
move forward now they still need to make
this right man turn here if got'em were
to move the bridge it would disappear
and reappear somewhere else if both of
them would end up in three lovely
Skylar's still got two unused portals so
ghost either put one there and then we
re extended up and you're right there
you go now head on through so Skylar's
been able to re-extend the bridge that
goddamn initially extended and put it
through a 90-degree Bend so if you just
hop down there Skylar okay so using for
portals you can actually make some
fairly complicated courageous
wedge between the two okay but I've been
studying blues performance and I don't
know how to put this I'm certain you're
driving very hard so the last puzzle
we're going to show you is a little bit
more complicated than these two and he
utilizes something that if you played
portal one you may remember put a portal
on ceiling and one on the floor and fall
through them and something called the
FIFA that fall 80 a lot of momentum is
kind of fun got achievement for it but
it didn't have any real practical
purpose and terms of puzzle solving and
co-op because it's two players we can
actually utilize this to problem-solve
condoms looking over at the exit where
the two of them need to get fortunately
there's no portal circ over there so the
campus portal / that swine so scatter if
you can just follow the guy around the
corner there Gotham is going to set up
an infinite fall for you
if you can hop in there Skyler and
yourself some momentum now the condoms
going to go over to the side let's see
there's an ankle portal circulation
God's going to move in portal and Skylar
is going to come rocketing out over the
good into that big date which got him
forgot to open so so there's no hard
feelings bunch of guys a hug it out here
so we've got a full suite of gestures
you can do by yourself but there's also
a whole bunch of teen gestures of both
unlock immediately and define okay so
let's let's do this one more time Skylar
and Gotham will will press the button
and you're over there perfect so you're
over on the other side Scylla but you
still need to get so want to head over
to where the buttons really try to you
there's go and set up an internet fall
for God market for you or is there one
down there you'll notice that one of
Gotham's portals are still down there
but you can just overwrite your
partner's portals alright so here we go
the government
and then
talk you're yellow
alright you overshot okay so there we go
teach you wanna keep moving out the door
there you go into just a little taste of
the portal to co-op experience is coming
out februari night 2011 now although be
seen back xbox 360 and ps3 thanks a lot
for coming with yr s to inform you that
you must now leave the theater